[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samba
ou de banane
allez
ses morceaux préférés j'adore bon bon
bon j'adore je le mets comme ça j'étais
en voiture l'achever des chauffeurs
rumeurs là ce week-end je les 1000
achever toutes mes courses comme ça j'ai
fait un kit mecheri je suis en voiture
je suis un feu il ya quelqu'un qui t'a
pas mon cas roues mais bon la personne
n'a reconnu
c'est devant la personne m'a reconnu on
est à un feu voilà la personne de me
parler et là je baisse sa vitre la
personne me dit bonjour monsieur ce que
vous pouvez me déposer make money where
jusqu'au point de déposer mais bon j'ai
pas de sou tout ça est ce que vous
pouvez me déposer comme vous êtes
chauffeur voilà serre sur votre réaction
donc c'est vrai que j'avais une voiture
qui fait un peu chauffeur et donc j'ai
pris le gars allez on dans la voiture
elle entendit je veux dit vas-y mon
frérot il est prêt à le gaver 88 ans
mais voilà mais je dis quand même offrir
ou et voilà donc il est venu je l'année
mais le pire c'est que après il m'a
engueulé mais non l'adar kaseja c'est
qu'à un moment j'ai récemment j'ai joué
sous mais là non je vous avais dit la
haye pays-bas - 5 le tour maintenant
mes héros notre calme et donc j'ai
refait le tour je les laissais bah oui
il en a franchement voilà et il m'a dit
bon il est parti même pas un merci n'est
rien mais rien directement vous avez
fait sa green it
j'ai fait ça gratuitement tu connais ou
pas les films d'horreur ça commence
toujours à l affût even avalanche jamais
prolongé chelou à la poupée
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe toby est mort
regardez ah oui c'est tout fait avec la
poupée mais seriez là ça commence qu'à
et reviennent à la maison
les fortes se ferment tout seul il ya
des mouches cammas de tout part dans les
films d'horreur il ya toujours des
mouches quelles nouvelles comme mon
frère tu as peur des mouches dans les
primes d'europe c'est le seul truc où le
moment pour te faire drame et mettre des
mouches frères moyens une mouche qu'on
ne dise pas grave car ce n'est pas un
film d'horreur rio ils mettent des
mouches partout
ah non mais je vous jure il ya des
objets chez louvroil et les geôliers qui
me font peur d'attaquer sa carrière je
dois prouver que je ne dirais pas
[Musique]
sursaut français combien pense que les
deux souris
crew croustillant donne encore plus
envie de faire je pense que quelqu'un
qui veut se rapprocher de moi sachez que
je joue je dis vous savez j'ai un
entraîneur qui s'occupe de kkr de serena
williams et si j'ai le même entraîneur
que serena williams oui ça s'appelle
patrick moratoglou
j'ai vu qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
était allé voir le match de serena
williams la finale perdue et je sens que
elle et elle y est allé pour me voir
regardez regardez un peu moins voilà
qu'à toi et ça soit moi vous kiffe la
wii mais payez vous non mais ce qui
classe évoqué l etat côté mon entraîneur
c'est évident alors là dedans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jusqu'où des comores